AND HAWAII'S EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ADMINISTRATOR RESIGN.
YOU'VE HEARD WHAT THE POLITICAL
EXPERTS PREDICT FOR TONIGHT'S
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS.
WHAT ABOUT THE EXPERTS IN
SENIOR CORRESPONDENT MIKE TOBIN
MICHIGAN COUNTY ABOUT WHAT THEY
EXPECT TO HEAR.
>> NESTLED ON THE BANKS OF
PRESIDENT EXCEPT CARTER IN THE
LAST 15 ELECTIONS.
VAN BUREN COUNTY IS A MIX OF
FARMS, AGRIBUSINESS,
MANUFACTURING AND SMALL
BUSINESS.
RESIDENTS ON THE RIGHT AND LEFT
CAN AGREE THIS PLACE IS NEITHER
TRUMP SUPPORTERS EXPECT A PEP
RALLY FROM THE PRESIDENT,
CELEBRATING ABOUNDS IN THE
ECONOMY AND THE RETURN OF JOBS.
>> I HOPE TO HEAR HIM GET UP
I DON'T THINK ENOUGH ATTENTION
HAS BEEN GIVEN TO THEM.
WE ARE ALREADY STARTING TO SEE
THE BENEFIT OF TAX REFORM.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
DOVETAILING THAT CAN HAPPEN WITH
THE MICHIGAN TURN AROUND.
>> OTHERS WHO DIDN'T VOTE FOR
TRUMP SAY THERE IS NOTHING HE
ACTION AND TRUST OVER TIME.
I MEAN, AND SO FAR THIS FIRST
YEAR HE'S DONE NONE OF THAT.
>> I DON'T THINK WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR ANYTHING NEW TONIGHT.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HIGHWAYS.
ON FOREIGN POLICY, PEOPLE ARE
HAPPY WITH ACTION IN ISRAEL.
SOME PEOPLE WANT A MESSAGE OF
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
ONE VETERAN JUST WANTS THE
PRESIDENT TO BE QUIET.
>> I SURE DON'T WANT TO HEAR
CAGE.
EVENTUALLY SOMEONE IS GOING TO
PULL THE TRIGGER.
>> IN A FARMING AREA THAT SEES A
LOT OF MIGRANT LABOR, PEOPLE
HERE WANT RESOLUTION ON
IMMIGRATION.
>> I WANT TO HEAR HIM SAY HE'S
GOING TO SECURE THE BORDER
BEFORE ANYBODY GETS ANY
CITIZENSHIP.
>> VAN BUREN COUNTY VOTERS WANT
TO HEAR A UNIFYING VOICE AMID
THE BITTER PARTISAN DIVIDE IN
CONGRESS AND ACROSS THE
HEARTLAND.
>> I AM LOOKING FOR A POSITIVE
TO BRIDGE SOME GAPS HERE AND GET
SOME BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
>> HE IS TRYING PRETTY HARD TO
BE A UNIFIER BUT ONE SIDE
DOESN'T WANT TO UNIFY.
>> IT'S POLARIZED BUT I'M NOT
SURE HE HAS HELPED THIS TOPIC.
>> PEOPLE HERE SAY THE VOICES
IN L.A.
HEART LEADERS WHO GET UP IN THE
HERE GOT A METHOD FOR THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN THAT HE WOULD GET THEM.